On social media,
you post a lot of behind-the-scenes content.
So, if it's okay,
we have a game here -
Yes!
we would love to play with you.
Yes, I would love to.
All right. It's the Final Five "Bridgerton" Edition!
(audience cheers and applauds)
All right, we're gonna ask you some juicy
behind-the-scenes Bridgerton questions,
and if you can spill the beans, we would love it.
Okay. Number one.
Which cast member is most likely to break in a scene?
Jonathan Bailey.
Oh really?
I didn't even have to think about that.
He's a terrible giggler.
And he plays this really brooding, like terrible rake,
and then he's like a little girl and he giggles.
(Ross laughs)
So, 100% him. 100%
Okay. I love that.
He's very handsome.
Yeah. Very handsome.
All right.
Well, Lady Whistledown's responsible
for all the gossip around town,
but who's the most gossipy cast member?
I'm just gonna nominate myself,
because I will be the one like, reading DeMoir,
and like, did you know this and this?
And I love like, but I think like, not all gossip is bad.
People perceive it as a terrible thing.
But like, you know when like celebrities get together a bit,
you know, been apart for a long time and get back together,
and then it's, like joyful.
Yes.
That's gossip, but that's like harmless, joyful gossip.
Understood.
I like the spin.
Right!
I'll accept it. Yes, I do.
Just make myself look good.
Yeah.
I believe we call it pop culture.
Thank you.
Absolutely.
That's what it is.
Consummate professional.
If the cast
has a group chat to stay in touch,
who's most likely to ghost the chat?
Oh, you know, I think Claudia Jessie, who plays Eloise.
Hm mm.
Because she does not like a group chat.
She's a one-on-one girl.
But she's not, like attached to her phone.
Like I'm always like, but yeah, probably Claudia.
She's like, I'm not into group chatting,
but she's like I'll talk to you one-on-one. (she laughs)
All right.
Well, which new character are you most excited about,
for everyone, for all of us to meet on season two?
There's a lot. I mean, of course the Sharma sisters.
They're just, Simone Ashley and Charithra Chandran,
who play Kate and Edwina,
are just gorgeous and wonderful.
And they're a big,
I saw someone doing this in the audience.
Yes!
Yes.
Look how excited they are!
Even the moment that I got cast in the show,
Kate is such a big character for the book fans.
She's like this real strong woman.
It's very "Pride and Prejudice" with her and Anthony.
She just doesn't take any of his rubbish, you know?
Okay.
A favorite and least favorite piece of wardrobe to wear?
Oh gosh, my favorite. Oh my gosh.
I have this pink dress this season,
and it's like something off a runway.
It's like Miu Miu-looking.
It's like fully beaded. It weighed a ton.
There was one scene where I had to run upstairs
and they're like, can you go quicker?
I was like, I physically, no.
(everyone laughs)
I was like chasing, I was like, oh.
Then I have,
oh are they gonna kill me for saying this,
Penelope's night gown,
her like, dressing gown that she wears?
Yeah.
It's just not the one.
Every day I walk into it, I'm like, not this!
Really!
But also,
it's part of Penelope,
is that that she's meant to be overdone
and it's too much and...
Yeah.
Well every choice that has been made along the way
and every choice that you specifically have made,
has just won us all over.
Thank you so much.
I'm so excited -
Oh my God.
that we're celebrating you!
(audience applauds)
Nicola Coughlan!
Season 2 of "Bridgerton" is available to stream
March 25th on Netflix.
(theme music plays out)